[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a thai television film
called ugly duckling perfect match
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
junita has an ideal life according to
most people she was born into a rich
family has a handsome boyfriend several
loving friends and most of all a pretty
face her biggest supporter is her
housekeeper aoe who loves her like her
own daughter one day junita's boyfriend
max picks her up for a date he
frequently compliments her looks and is
only dating her for her status the
couple is quite popular on instagram and
has collected several fans throughout
the years they meet some friends in a
cafe and as always junita is the center
of attention the next morning she wakes
up to several hate comments on her most
recent instagram picture people claim
she has a wide face and compare it to a
car wheel and a pancake junita who has
been called pretty her entire life is
heartbroken by the comments she receives
a call from max who also affirms that
she has gained weight on her face ginita
starts to work out starting the next day
being a good mentor aoi supports her but
also insists that she is pretty just the
way she is junita's mother on the other
hand does not feel the same way the
mother and daughter have to attend a
reality show in a few weeks hence she
wants junita to be in shape
after two weeks of eating healthy and
exercising she loses two kilos and feels
confident the next day she meets max yet
again and goes on another date while
they're at it he takes a picture of her
eating in which the angle makes her face
look rounder it is accidentally posted
on instagram and soon several negative
comments about her face flood the
comment section junita is saddened that
even after all the hard work she wasn't
able to lose weight on her face her
friend suggests she get botox as the
last resort initially junita is
skeptical scared of getting even more
backlash for the procedure still she
goes to consult a doctor after being
convinced she gets injected with fillers
and returns home hoping to look
different the next day she does look
different but not in the way she had
thought the botox has made her face
swell when she visits the doctor with
concern he reveals that she is allergic
to botox by now her face is completely
filled with rashes that will only go
away after a year-long treatment she
returns home disheartened and tells her
mother about the recovery time the
mother is distressed that she cannot
attend the event with her but asks her
to cheer up junita then calls her
friends hoping to meet them and get her
mind off of things but to her surprise
they refuse to be her friend anymore the
next day max comes to meet her and is
startled by her face he also makes an
excuse about going abroad for studies
and suggests they take a break from each
other
that night junita is at her lowest when
she discovers a website called the ugly
duckling it is a safe place for all
conventionally unattractive people to
share their experiences she signs up to
the website and makes some friends after
listening to her story one of them
suggests she consult a popular skin
specialist in another city if she gets
treated by the doctor the recovery might
be sooner junita decides to move to
another city and start a new life now
that she can no longer go to her former
school she tells her mother about the
plan who agrees to let her move but only
if aoy accompanies her junita accepts
the deal with no fuss since aoy is like
a mother to her while they prepare to
leave junita changes her surname so none
of her former friends and fans can track
her down she hopes to live a normal life
and make genuine friends this time in
the following scene aoi and junita
arrive at her new school junita has a
scarf wrapped around her face so people
won't judge her for her looks although
the school is a downgrade from her
previous one she is ready to compromise
when she first walks in a handsome guy
named leo offers her help he is so
attractive that junita forgets to speak
and just stares at him a few seconds
later leo asks her if she is mute and
she manages to blurt out that she needs
directions to the principal's office as
they talk we find out that they both
study in the same faculty leo invites
her to a welcome program that the
seniors have hosted for the newcomers
later she goes to the program and meets
a funny guy named b his personality
makes him easy to talk to so she
instantly befriends him the president of
the cheer club tui introduces himself to
everyone he expects the newcomers to
respect the older students and stay
submissive since the guys are attractive
no one seems to mind following their
orders they organize a dance battle that
junita thoroughly enjoys she is happy
for the first time since the facelift
fiasco which gives her hope of a steady
ride during her time in the school
junita and eoi then visit the hostel
where they are supposed to stay three
girls who are already waiting for a
fourth roommate invite junita to stay
with them and provide aoy with another
room the girls excitedly enter their
dorm room to see that it is congested
and dirty still they settle in happy to
finally have found a friend group in the
new place the girls introduce themselves
as ning nui and joy ning is friendlier
than the other two as she urges junita
to feel at home with them as they talk
junita's scarf slides down and her face
scares nui and joy ning however tells
her that it's okay and asks her about
her rashes after junita tells them her
story she feels bad for her and lets her
stay with them much to the other girl's
annoyance when junita is not in the room
they complain about living together with
someone who looks like a ghost ning
shuts them down asserting that junita
will return to her normal self in a year
junita overhears their conversation from
the bathroom and is heartbroken she
cries alone for a few minutes before
joining them again the following day she
wears a big pair of sunglasses and a
scarf to hide her face the freshmen have
gathered for a program her friends urge
her to take the scarf off but she
refuses the president of the cheer club
tui sees them chatting and is furious at
them for not paying attention to the
program he brings junita in front of
everyone and urges her to take her scarf
off ginita shakes in fear but still
refuses to take it off out of
embarrassment then leo comes to her side
and promises to protect her but he also
asks her to take the scarf off for now
since tui will not let the matter go
until he gets what he wants junita
reluctantly does is told and makes the
crowd gasp at her face everyone starts
whispering and laughing at her making
her feel more awful than she already
does she looks at leo to read his
expression but he doesn't give away what
he is thinking tui laughs hysterically
and encourages the others to make fun of
her calling her a ghost the humiliation
is too much for junita to take and she
starts to cry the crowd only stops
chanting when leo speaks on her behalf
he asks them to come forward and show
everyone how they look before bashing
jenita for something she cannot control
he also makes the crowd apologize to her
including tui jenita is touched by the
gesture and stops wearing the scarf
because of him she feels confident in
her skin for the first time in a long
time the event continues where the
students take part in several games then
it is announced that the freshman's
attitude is the most important factor
that makes them a true student of their
school hence to test their character the
seniors have planted a spy among us
i mean among them the spy turns out to
be none other than ning she affirms that
all the freshers have unique and great
personalities following that the
newcomers are paired with a respective
senior who will work as their guide for
the first semester junita is paired up
with leo much to her delight after the
program she spots ning and leo together
it is soon revealed that the two are a
couple junita feels a pang of jealousy
but hides it efficiently she also goes
to the skin specialist who adds a few
pills to her medication for accelerated
recovery junita feels confident that she
will get back her old clear skin in no
time one day she and her roommates are
passing their time by telling each other
horror stories the rain outside makes
the atmosphere even more frightening
suddenly their roof starts to leak
making them panic they pack their
luggage and run to the receptionist
asking for another room to stay in
however all the rooms in the hostel are
packed junita's roommates find a place
for the night and leave her there alone
she tries calling aoi but cannot reach
her as a last resort she calls ning and
asks to stay at her place for the night
when she goes to her apartment she
figures out that the couple lives
together leo is financially weak and
struggling to earn money for school fees
hence he stays with ning currently he
leaves the bed for the girls and sleeps
on the floor for the night the following
morning junita wakes up to see leo
shivering she puts a blanket over him
when he unconsciously snuggles closer to
her junita somehow gets free from his
embrace but doesn't notice him smiling
it is evident that he held her close on
purpose the next day at school b junita
leo and ning decide to go out to eat leo
gets on his scooter which refuses to
start ning repeatedly asks him to get a
new one inconsiderate of the fact that
he cannot afford it moreover he
accidentally breaks his slippers while
trying to start the scooter as he fixes
it ning feels humiliated she throws the
sandals away and storms off leo still
insists that they go through with the
plan and go out to eat in the following
scene the three are at a restaurant on
being asked what she thinks about the
argument ginita claims that ning must
have been worried for him since the old
scooter might have caused an accident
leo understands and calls ning to
apologize like a good boyfriend
following that junita moves into the
apartment next to ning and leo deciding
to stay there until the dorm ceiling is
fixed aoe also moves in with her to help
her with household work she is
especially impressed with leho's
handsomeness and urges junita to be his
girlfriend the two then go out to a
restaurant for lunch to junita's
surprise ning enters the restaurant with
a man who is not leo junita hides her
face with a menu and eavesdrops on their
conversation it is revealed that the
guy's name is todd and he is ning's
second boyfriend he is a rich man loved
by ning's parents who are also wealthy
hence they want tot to be ning's
boyfriend not leo junita tries her best
to stay hidden but ning happens to see
her she quickly leaves before the
situation gets more awkward at night she
can hardly fall asleep thinking about
the events of the day leo has been
nothing but nice to her which puts her
in a dilemma as to whether she should
tell him the truth the next day during
lunch break the group is hanging out
together when leo gets a call from an
unknown number ning gets mad at him
assuming that the number belongs to a
girl although leo insists that he hasn't
given his number to anyone she walks
away furiously junita quietly huffs
baffled by ning's hypocrisy all of a
sudden tot arrives at the school to
surprise ning he sits with junita and
the group waiting for his girlfriend to
return junita nervously keeps the
conversation going but tot doesn't stop
talking about ning when a furious leo
asks him how he knows nang he reveals
that she is his girlfriend it turns out
that she told tot she broke up with leo
a long time ago the men get into a fight
and only stop when ning returns leo asks
her what she wants to which ning replies
that her parents will never accept him
because of his financial condition she
doesn't love him enough to go against
her parents and knows that someday they
will have to separate at last the two
break up before leo walks away he
doesn't come to school for the next week
and doesn't pick up anyone's calls
junita is constantly worried about him
her friends start to suspect that she
likes him but she is quick to shut the
rumpus down then in the last scene leo
approaches junita out of nowhere and
surprises her junita had missed him so
much that she hugs him instantly the
embrace sparks a warm feeling in leo as
well junita finally has someone who
likes her for who she is and not because
of her money beauty or status they talk
for a long time indicating the start of
a new relationship
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching